So new game Demo
05 from
Turkey so I'm just trying out
different openings now
I'll see if I can get the result here
filidor takes away and swaps
the dam I think the variant is
not particularly dangerous for Black
although I have to say D I  I do
n't know much about it either, so
you always have to look at it in relative terms,
so yes, the one next to here that
creates a double pawn is actually
never a big problem. I'll
first take away the squares here,
well I just attack the bishop C5 and the pawn
h ignores that  he simply
and attacks the
mh yes F2 should take it should be cheese
bishop G4 I have
a bit of concerns about knight E5 maybe it
won't work at all but well I'll just take a
normal move that E5
covers so it's
gone back. The question is whether  Here
bishop G3 is a problem to
attack here
h I can't cover it well at the moment
H
I just have an idea to attack knight G4
again F2
so I hope I've now
seen correctly that he can
somehow cover it with the rook  Does
he have to or can make any strange moves
Knight G5
maybe rook covers I wanted to
play F6 and then you can move the knight
to H6
Knight B6 and maybe King E7
Bishop E6 with this one with the chain F6 E5
everything is securely covered here and he
also has one  strange
position of the bishop yes, of course that
might be a good idea because he now
occupies D8 here so I
move the knight rook D8 mat W a bit
embarrassing so I could still play bishop E7
and make me either
go back or swap I'll do
that
W  now bishop E7 King E7 then
the king should actually help quite a bit
okay he's going away from there so then
I'll do F6 and cover the whole
thing
so now his bishop is in a
bad position on
G3 I'm of course
still standing a bit cramped here he's
faster  Well, with moves like Rook
D1 and so on, but it doesn't threaten anything, so
now the
question is how we can best get the
parts untied here.
Knight
B6,
well I actually have to
swap that one somehow, maybe Knight F8 with that
Idea runner
E6 yes, that's a bit slow,
but it's a good thing I don't need many moves
to get myself back on track
so that I don't have any
immediate problems if I
manage to do runner E6 and swap, for example,
then not much will happen here at
first  and then you can see how you
move on, thank you, it's
not exactly fast either, so I,
as a white person, would now, yes, I
thought about that for a moment, but I could
n't
believe it,
so well, I'll probably have to take it away
if I play now, for example  Knight
F7 I also have this
move Bishop F6 can he really threaten next to rook D8
that doesn't do anything,
okay,
but I would like to calm things down here
if it somehow
works like that Bishop F7 King F7 should
n't be a problem now
so and now white  I don't know where he's
going exactly, I now have the idea G5 with
the pin on the
rook, so now he has to look where he's
going with the bishop he
takes, which he takes away straight away,
so okay bishop G5 drot still and
the g pawn
hangs three pawns  he has now
come out so well for that, somehow I
still do
n't do it, I'll try to see if I
can tie here W I can just see that
Rook D8 might work here,
hm I have to play King G7
h looks uncomfortable, well let's
see what he
draws
try to
walk through there
E6
unpleasant yes that's very difficult
Position is strange and I have nothing
on the
clock the move is also supposed to prevent G4 but
I think this looks super
dangerous of course just tower D8 and stuff like that
okay I can't get in there
hm if I do that  completely blocked here,
then it works again, apart
from the
reflection time.
Check
Check black forfits on time, just
when a winning position has been
reached again. Time exceeded. Somehow
I already know that
somehow then fought out but
the position was of course
definitely
lost in between, yes that's it  here even matt yes
Springer
C3 yes it's
a shame